>> HAPPY MONDAY!
[ APPLAUSE ]
I HOPE YOU HAD A GREAT WEEKEND.
I DID.
AFTER I CLEARED UP THE
MISUNDERSTANDING WITH THE PARK
POLICE.
WHEN DID RESTROOM CUSTODIANS
START WORKING UNDERCOVER.
IT APPEARS THAT THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT IS USING VIDEO OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE FROM
PHILADELPHIA IN A NATIONAL AD
CAMPAIGN TO TRY TO SCARE YOUNG
PEOPLE AWAY FROM DRUGS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> SPEAK ENGLISH?
A THIRD WORLD COUNTRY TAKING
SHOTS AT A FAILED DEMOCRAT-RUN
CITY.
IT DEPICTS BROTHERLY LOVE BETTER
THAN TWO GUYS SHARING A DIRTY
NEEDLE.
ONLY CITY WORSE OFF IN PHILLY IS
POMPEO.
THEY HAD AN EXCUSE.
ONE VOLCANO ERUPTS AND THEY CALL
IT A DAY.
NOT BOTHERING TO BUILD IT BACK
UP.
GROW A PAIR.
PEOPLE OBJECTED TO BEING FILMED.
THAT'S ANOTHER PROBLEM.
THESE SCENES WERE FILMED IN
PUBLIC.
UNLIKE THOSE VIDEOS CAME FROM
THE LOCKER ROOM AT THE YMCA.
GOT A SHAMPOO BOTTLE WITH A HOLE
IN IT.
IT'S HARD TO GIVE CONSENT WHEN
YOUR PANTS ARE DOWN ON THE
SIDEWALK.
YOU WANT THAT GUY TO SIGN A
WAIVER?
YOU NEED A PAIR OF SALAD TONGS.
MEXICO IS THE BIG SOURCE OF
FENTANYL THAT KILLED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS.
MEXICO TELLS THEIR PEOPLE, DO
NOT BE LIKE OUR CUSTOMERS.
IT'S LIKE RONALD McDONALD
TELLING RONALD JR. TO LAY OFF
THE BIG MAC.
IT'S THE BEST ADVICE.
DON'T GET HIGH ON YOUR OWN
SUPPLY.
IT'S A FAVORITE ADVICE CORNER
DRUG DEALERS AND THE HOBBY SHOP
WHERE I BUY MY GLUE.
IT'S AWESOME SAYING, STAY AWAY
FROM PHILLY.
YEAH, IT'S SAD.
WE HAVE REACHED A POINT WHERE
WE'RE NOW THE TRAVEL HAZARDS.
NOT THE OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> HELLO FOLKS.
>> WE'RE BEING SPONTANEOUS AND
TAKING A TRIP.
WHAT'S THE NEXT FLIGHT OUT?
>> IT'S VERY LAST MINUTE.
ALL I GOT LEFT IS PHILADELPHIA
AND FALLUJAH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT DOWN THE MILL
FOR ME.
>> DO YOU HAVE A RECOMMENDATION?
>> WELL, THEY'RE THE SAME
FRANKLY.
I HEAR IRAQ IS REALLY NICE THIS
TIME OF YEAR.
>> OKAY.
FALLUJAH HERE WE COME.
>> HERE'S YOUR TICKETS HERE IS
YOUR BODY ARMOR.
SORRY, THAT'S FOR PHILADELPHIA.
>> THAT MAKES SENSE
>> ENJOY YOUR FLIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> WE CAN LAUGH AT THIS.
WHO'S GOT A BETTER POLICY?
MEXICO OR US?
IN NEW YORK GUY WAS ARRESTED FOR
20,000 FENTANYL PILLS.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH CRIMINAL
POSSESSION AND RELEASED ON HIS
ON RECOGNIZANCE.
WHAT DID THEY THINK HE'LL DO
NEXT?
RETURN TO HIS JOB IN FINANCE?
GET BACK TO SQUASH LESSONS.
HE'S NOW CURRENTLY AT AN ORPHAN
AVERAGE READING BEDTIME STORIES.
THE PROBLEM WITH SOCIETY, WE
MADE LOW GRADE ADDICTION
INCOMPATIBLE.
IT'S FAR FROM PERFECT.
BUT STILL, CAT COMES IN TO WORK
SEVERAL TIMES A WEEK
>> WHY YOU STILL LAUGHING AT
THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WE DON'T DO THAT WITH
OPIOIDS.
WE PUNISH THE LEGAL PATIENT AND
LET THE ILLEGAL STUFF FLOW.
WHAT DOES THAT SOUND LIKE?
GUN CONTROL.
TARGETING THE LAW-ABIDING AND
LETTING THE LAW BREAKERS GO
FREE.
YOU KNOW HOW WELL THAT WORKS.
THE CASUALTIES ARE MAINLY THE
YOUNG BECAUSE THEY TAKE THE
RISK.
100 YEARS AGO THEY BOOZED FROM
THE BATHTUB AND SOMETIMES THEY
DIED.
THE SAME THING WOULD HAPPEN IF
YOU DRANK FROM MY BATHTUB TODAY.
I HAVEN'T CLEANED IT SINCE HE
FIRST EPISODE OF "RED EYE" SAME
THING HAPPENS WITH FENTANYL.
THAT'S BECAUSE OUR JOB POLICY
MADE RECREATIONAL DRUG USE WORSE
THAN RUSSIAN ROULETTE.
THERE IS LITTLE IF ANY DATA ON
WHO'S DYING.
THAT'S WEIRD.
WHEN YOU SEE THAT VIDEO OF THE
PHILLY ZOMBIES, HOW MANY DO DO
YOU THINK THERE'S STILL ALIVE?
MAY BE I SHOULD START POOPING
OUTDOORS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
SHE'S AS HOT AS GRAVY AND STILL
SERVES IN THE NAVY, FORMER STATE
DEPARTMENT SPOKESWOMAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HE'S THE WAR VET WHO LOOKS GOOD
WET.
ROB SMITH.
WHEN HE HEARD MEN CAN GET
PREGNANT, HE WENT ON MATERNITY
LEAVE.
WRITER COMEDIAN, JOE MACKEY!
AND FINALLY, SHE'S GOT A CASE OF
THE MONDAYS, AND EBOLA.
JOE, WELCOME BACK.
I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU HAD THE
SURGERY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> GREAT TO BE BACK.
I'M A LITTLE BEHIND ON THE NEWS
STUFF.
WE'RE HAPPY YOU'RE NOT CNN PLUS.
THAT WENT AWAY BUT YOU CAME
BACK.
>> I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
GREAT STUDIO AUDIENCE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I BROUGHT YOU BACK HERE SO I
CAN TELL YOU TO LEAVE.
WHEN OTHER COUNTRIES START USING
AMERICA AS A CAUTIONARY TALE,
THAT IS QUITE A MESSAGE.
>> IT'S BAD.
IT'S INTERESTING INSTEAD OF
SAYING, SOME OF THE CRITICISM
WAS JUSTIFIED, THEY MAKE IT SEEM
LIKE DRUG ADDICTS WERE VICTIMS
BECAUSE THEY WERE ANYMORED IN
PUBLIC.
>> THEY PLAYED TECHNO MUSIC?
>> THEY DO.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU LIKE TO ADD?
>> YEAH, IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
PHILADELPHIA ALMOST ACTED LIKE A
DRUG ADDICT WHEN YOU CALL THEM
ON THE PROBLEM, THEY THROW IT
BACK AT YOU.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY JOE YOU'RE
ADDICTED TO SNACKING, I SAY,
YOUR GIRLFRIEND LEFT YOU FOR
CARNIVAL CARL.
HIS NAME WAS CARL.
>> WELCOME.
ONCE AGAIN, YOU JUST OUT DRESS
EVERYBODY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I DO COMMENT ON WHAT PEOPLE WEAR
AT WORK.
WHY IS IT NOT A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE?
>> IT IS.
I THINK IT'S THE MOST NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
WHEN YOU HAVE OTHER NATIONS
CRITICIZING THE U.S., YOU HAVE A
NARCO STATE THAT'S TELLING
PHILADELPHIA THAT YOU HAVE A
DRUG PROBLEM.
THAT'S KIND OF BAD.
>> THAT'S WHEN THE DEALER SAY,
PULL BACK ON THE HEROIN.
>> WHY DIDN'T BIDEN MEET WITH XI
JINPING, LEADER OF CHINESE
COMMUNITY PARTY, THE CHEMICAL
PRECURSOR FROM FENTANYL COME
FROM CHINA.
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE KILLER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CLEARLY MORE
IMPORTANT THAN GETTING A
STATISTIC ON HOW MANY PEOPLE
ACTUALLY DIE FROM THIS.
>> YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
EXCEPT THAT IT DOUBLED.
THEY USED TO SAY OVERDOSES.
IT'S ALWAYS FENTANYL MIXED WITH
CAFFEINE OR ANOTHER DRUG.
I READ A LOT OF IT.
I DON'T THINK I GOT ANY SMARTER.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
WHAT SHOULD BIDEN HAVE DONE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
BIDEN SHOULD HAVE PROBABLY HAD A
SPINE.
THAT WILL BE EXPECTING TOO MUCH
MUCH.
WHEN WE SAW THAT COMMERCIAL,
THAT PARTY LOOKED INCREDIBLE.
I WANTED TO GO TO THAT PARTY.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
THEY TO OUTSOURCE THE FOOTAGE TO
THE DRUG ADDICTS ON THE STREETS.
I WAS WONDERING IS THERE SOME
SORT OF LIKE WEIRD FAILED
DEMOCRATIC CITY GETTY IMAGE
WHERE IS THEY CAN FIND VIDEOS
OUTSIDE OF McDONALD'S OR
PEOPLE SHOOTING UP OUTSIDE OF
PRESCHOOL.
>> I SEEN THAT VIDEO A LOT.
IT'S VIDEO WHERE EVERYBODY'S
FACES ARE BLURRED.
IT'S BEEN AROUND SINCE SLOW
MOTION.
IT'S INCREDIBLY -- IT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE AMERICA.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE ANYTHING.
>> I'VE BEEN TO BOTH TO IRAQ AND
PHILADELPHIA.
I WILL PREFER IRAQ.
>> ANYBODY HERE FROM PHILLY?
NEVER GOT OUT.
SO SAD.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
BY THE WAY, WHAT DO YOU MAKE FOR
LEGALIZATION, SHOULD THAT DUDE
WITH 20,000 PILLS BE LEFT GO?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT DRUG
CRIMES ARE CRIMES.
I DON'T THINK THAT -- YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO BUY PILLS WHERE YOU
KNOW THERE'S NO FENTANYL IN IT.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE OUT ON THE
STREET, THEY MIGHT BE DOING
FENTANYL ON PURPOSE.
IT'S NOT LIKE SOMEONE ONE OF THE
YOUTHS WILL SEE THAT VIDEO AND
BE LIKE, OH, I GUESS I WON'T GO
TO THAT FENTANYL PARTY ON
PURPOSE.
>> 20,000 PILLS.
>> IT'S A LOT.
IT'S PROBABLY NOT PEOPLE SAYING
I LIKE TO BY FENTANYL PLEASE.
>> THEY ARE PUTTING THEM IN
COCAINE AND ECSTASY PILLS.
SOME KIDS MIGHT WANT TO DO PARTY
DRUG AND THEY DIE.
>> THAT'S WHY THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT NUMBERS.